[Musique]
mardi 6 février bonsoir et bienvenue
dans le 78 sur tv78 voici les titres de
cette
édition le centre aqualudique Castalia à
morpa dans le viseur de certains
habitants un collectif dénonce la forte
hausse des tarifs de location des lignes
d'eau elle conduirait selon ses m à une
chute de la fréquentation des publics
scolaires des arguments contrés par le
maire de la commune Grégory garestier
les précisions à suivre saviez-vous que
la première ligne de chemin de fer
transportant des voyageurs en France a
vu le jour dans les Yvelines c'était en
1837 à Saint-Germain en Lay cette
anecdote et bien d'autres encore vous
sont livré au gré de balade commenté sur
le tramois T13 une guide conférencière
vous permet de mieux connaître
l'histoire des villes traversées par la
ligne inaugurée en 2022 une découverte
dans cette édition le taille jitu est
une méthode française de self défense
basée sur plusieurs techniques d'arts
martiaux ce sport est pratiqué par plus
de 80 adhérents au club de Montini le
Bretonneux l'association propose des
cours des l'âge de 6 ans et puis
l'invité du 78 en 2e partie d'émission
on y parle du sing tank des élus du
handicap du département des Yvelines son
but partager les bonnes expériences dans
les communes et faire remonter les
besoins spécifiques sur le sujet auprès
des maires députés et pourquoi pas du
gouvernement nous recevrons la
présidente de l'association émil le
tailleur conseillère municipal de
jillant Josas délégué au handicap et en
plateau dès le début de cette édition
Clara de Frutos bonsoir bonsoir
journaliste de la rédaction de tv78 on
va faire le point tout de suite avec
vous sur les informations du
jour et on a appris que Jean-Philippe lu
le maire de boisarcy annoncé sa
démission sur sur dans une lettre
publiée sur facebook j'allais dire sur
Twitter c'était sur facebook oui
exactement dans son communiqué l'élu
fait référence à son activité
professionnelle les conditions ne sont
malheureusement plus réunies pour que je
puisse terminer mon mandat sereinement
notamment car mon activité
professionnelle que j'ai toujours
souhaité poursuivre me demande de plus
en plus de temps il évoque aussi un
mandat particulièrement difficile suite
à la la crise sanitaire énergétique et
inflationniste Jean-Philippe lu était
devenu maire de boisarcy en novembre
2020 ladyadressera sa démission au
préfet des yvelin dans les 15 jours
suivant la démission du maire le conseil
municipal devra réunir afin de procéder
à l'élection d'un nouveau maire et de et
de ses adjoints pardon je m'étouffe dans
l'actualité de ce mardi 6 février
également Clara cette nouvelle
mobilisation des enseignants une grève
qui était à l'appel de des principaux
syndicats d'enseignants oui et le
mouvement national a été suivi dans les
Yvelines parmi les établissements
mobilisés le collège de La Coudre à
Montini le Bretonneux où selon le
collectif des enseignants 70 % d'entre
eux ont répondu au préavis de grff
déposé ce mardi parmi leurs
revendication le manque de moyens
humains leurs conditions de travail ou
encore la perte de moyens horaires euh
de l'établissement Gabriel gonther était
sur place ça fait plusieurs années qu'on
perd des moyens horaires sur notre
dotation cette année on perd à nouveau
6h50 de dotations horaire en heure
d'enseignement pour nos élèves et euh
tout cela associé aux nouvelles
directives avec des groupes de niveau en
6e et en 5e en mathématiques et en
français fait qu'on perd plus d'une
vingtaine d'heures d'enseignement pour
not
élèves parmi les enseignants cette
baisse de la de la dotation horaire
globale menace également certains cours
et sixtion au sein de l'établissement le
fait que il y ait des groupes de niveau
ça va forcément impacter toutes les
autres matières à savoir que tous les
demi-groupes qui étaient mis en place
qu'on appelle la paix ça va en fait être
complètement dstructuré il n'y aura plus
de demi-groupe alors que nous avons des
effectifs d'environ 30 élèves par classe
donc ça implique plus de travaux
pratiques des séances àinformatique qui
sont impossibles en mathématiques en
technologie dans toutes les
matières en réponse à ce mouvement les
enseignants ont obtenu un rendez-vous
prochainement avec la directrice
académique des services de l'éducation
nationale aucune information n'a été
donnée pour le moment concernant la
reconduction du mouvement on parle à
présent avec vous des nouvelles mesures
du rapport d'ivramet ça concerne la
ligne B du RER le but c'est de réduire
les retards et donc ces ces
préconisations sont mises en place par
Île-de France mobilité la SNCF et la
RATP depuis 7 semaines oui pour rappel
ce rapport avait été commandé en 2023
par Valérie pcres présidente
d'Île-de-France mobilité et de la région
Île-de-France l'objectif était de mettre
en place un plan d'action pour améliorer
le service du RERB et gagner un point de
ponctualité par an jusqu'en 2025 pour
cela elle a notamment mandaté ivramet
expert ferroviaire et ancien directeur
général de la RATP 14 mesures concrètes
ont alors été définies certaines sont
sont déjà mis en place parmi les
nouveautés le RERB dispose de six trains
supplémentaires aptes à rouler
l'ensemble des trains seront aussi dotés
de puces GPS pour mieux gérer le parc en
exploitation et pour mieux traiter les
incidents les conducteurs de train sont
autorisés depuis juin 2023 à rouler au
pas lorsque je cite une intrusion non
avérée est signalée selon nos confrères
du Parisien Laurent souvinier directeur
de la ligne du RERB affirme que les
chiffres du mois de janvier sont encour
encourageant 86, 7 % des trains étaient
à l'heure ce mois-ci contre 82,9 % en
janvier 2023 il é il était amarré au
quai des vins de l' depuis 2008 le yacht
de Churchill va quitter les EV puis
qu'il a été vendu à un collectionneur
anglais l'Amazon de son vrai nom va
retrouver sa terre natale au sud de
l'Angleterre le Yach dont la légende dit
qu'il a appartenu à Wiston Churchill a
levé les voiles ce lundi 5 février vers
11h il sera d'abord remorqué jusqu'au
port du Havre avant de traverser la
Manche sur un semiubmersible son nouveau
propriétaire serait un riche anglais
dont l'identité n'a pas été dévoilée et
concernant le prix de vente le prix de
vente même chose le chiffre reste un
mystère en 2016 le prix était fixé à 1,9
million d'euros avant de descendre à
600000 € quoi qu'il arrive on parle
d'une grosse somme on termine en musique
Lara ce weekend avait lieu la finale du
trempelin des voix c'était à la Maison
de l'Environnement de manilé amau
exactement 20 candidats étaient en liste
pour le concours de champ national à la
clé des heures de coaching et des suivis
personnalisés parmi les lauréat de cette
9e édition on retrouve loudeleuse qui
remporte la première place dans la
catégorie 17 ans et moins STL remporte
quant à elle le prix de la meilleure
interprète dans la catégorie 18 ans et
plus et enfin li a obtenu le premier
prix dans la catégorie auteur
compositeur interprète voici quelques
extraits de leur prestation
[Musique]
voyageyage plus loin
que la nuit le
[Musique]
J je me suis cassé la gueule en tomous
charme dans un tapis de fleur aromatis
de Mus je suis
C bravo gagnante de cette 9e édition du
Tremplin des VO merci à
vous information et comme d'habitude si
vous aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une actualité qui vous fait
réagir dans les evvelin n'hésitez pas à
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
new des craintes exprimé par le
collectif piscine pour tous à morpa
elles sont liées à des tarifs jugés trop
élevés de la location des lignes d'eau
au centre aqualudique Castalia
conséquent selon ses membres une chute
de la fréquentation des publics
scolaires pour le maire de mort pas
Grégory garestier ses coups ne sont pas
comparables en raison d'équipement
différents entre l'ancienne piscine de
la ville et la structure actuelle le
point sur la situation avec Julien Leroi
des bassins trop cher pour les scolaires
à l'ouverture en 2022 du centre
aqualudique Castalia à morepa le
collectif piscine pour tous s'inquiète
en cause des augmentations de tarifs sur
la location des lignes d'eau entre
l'ancienne piscine municipale fermée en
2015 et le nouveau complexe pour appel
morpa et encours signa le contrat de
délégation de service publics en jean
2020 confiant à la société Fage la
construction et exploitation de Castalia
selon la quarantaine de membres du
collectif les principales victimes sont
les écoles du territoire les élèves les
les collèges et les lycées ne pouvant
plus venir à la piscine en raison du
cout exorbitant des lignes d'eau qui
sont passé de 6,50 € en 2015 à 46,60 €
en 2022 donc à l'époque de la piscine
municipale au collège PERG nous avions
les moyens d'emmener toutes nos classes
à la piscine évidemment les choix ont dû
se faire et c'est la classe de 6e qui a
été choisie pour bénéficier de cet
enseignement pour le maire de morepa
Grégory garestier ces tarif s'inscrivve
dans la moyenne des équipements des
alentours il réaffirme qu'il est à la
charge des communes de financer les
créneaux de natation pour les élèves des
écoles maternelles et primaires en ce
qui concerne les collèges et les lycées
des crédits pour les locations des
lignes d'eau leur sont allouées par le
département et la région aujourd'hui sur
la totalité des établissements on en a
un qui rencontre des difficultés mais
qui rencontre des difficultés également
liées à des problématiques de gestion au
sein de son établissement avec des choix
peut-être d'action pédagogiques qui ont
été faites dans les années passées quand
l'équipement était fermé et aujourd'hui
c'est plus difficile j'allais dire de
faire des arbitrage il compare un tarif
de 2014 ou 2015 qui n'a rien à voir ce
n'est pas du tout le même équipement
l'équipement dont il parle à 6 € la
ligne d'eau j'allais dire il était déjà
payé puisque c'est la ville de morpa qui
en a récupéré la gestion en 1983 quand
elle est sortie de 50 ans neline
contacter le centre aqualudique Castalia
n'a pas souhaité répondre à nos
sollicitations ce mardi 6 février les
membres du collectif piscine pour tous
se réuniront dans la soirée devant
l'entrée du conseil municipal de morepa
ils souhaitent rencontrer le maire pour
exprimer leurs
craintes
allez on ouvre une page culture dans le
[Musique]
78 l'Office de Tourisme de Saint-Germain
boucle de scène propose une visite
insolite à bord du tramou t33 animé par
une guide conférencière la ligne relie
Saint-Germain à saint-sirlécole et
regorge de trésors patrimoniaux et
historiques Mathilde Francou vous les
fait découvrir dans ce reportage lorsque
le premier chemin de faire pour
voyageurs a été inventé en France
c'était entre Paris et Saint-Germain
ENL attention départ imminent l'Office
de Tourisme de Saint-Germain boucle de
scène vous embarque pour une visite
commentée à bord du nouveau tramou T3
group c'est une visite qui relie deux
grands domaines historiques qui fait la
part belle aussi aux écomobilités c'est
bien d'expliquer à ceux qui utilisent le
tram un pourquoi il est là de c'est pas
une un hasard Saint-Germain c'est
vraiment le résultat d'une très vieille
histoire liée au transport depuis le 19e
siècle et puis c'est aussi le but de se
dire qu'on prend pas le tram juste pour
être dans le tram mais qu'il y a des
choses à voir à gauche et à droite et ça
peut être des suggestions de visite des
suggestions de visite comme l'école
militaire de saint-sirlécole la forêt de
Marle ou encore les vergers de l'étan la
ville installé confortablement dans le
tram vous découvrirez l'histoire et le
patrimoine des villes qu'il traverse on
voit bien les Verchers je vous parlais
tout à l'heure il a vraiment situé ça
dans les
vergers nous avons eu un superbe guide
qui nous a très bien commenter on a
appris beaucoup de choses de
connaissance super franchement est très
un guide est très très compétente
franchement on a a appris plein de
choses quoi que je peux pas dire là
parce que j'ai oublié maisf bon c'est
vraiment bien vous en saurez également
plus sur l'histoire de ces raill qui
date de 1837 compta environ 1 heure et
demi de visite et 12 € par personne sans
le titre de transport prochaine visite
le 4 mai à 11h ou
14h30 d'histoire il en est à question
chaque mardi dans le 78 Maxence de la
Crouée jeune ivelinois passionné par
l'histoire vous en apprend plus sur le
département ce soir Maxens nous parle de
la commanderie de la ville dieieu à
hlencour quand vous allez à hencour vous
pensez forcément à France Miniature je
vous l'accorde mais n'oubliez pas la
commanderie de viledieu terre chargée
d'histoire
la Commanderie a été fondée au 12e
siècle par l'Ordre du Temple qui
rassemblait des moines chevaliers que
l'on appelait Templiers leur objectif
partir en croisade à Jérusalem pour
reconquérir le tombeau de Jésus aux
mains des musulmans la commanderie de la
ville dieieu a la même utilité que les
300 autres commanderies de France elle
héberge des activités militaires pour
préparer les hommes avant de partir en
croisade des activités financières
l'exploitation de terr agricoes pour
financer les expéditions et des
activités religieuses pour préparer
spirituellement les Templiers la
Commanderie est très réputée pour sa
proximité avec la capitale et sa
superficie la commanderie de la ville
Dieu a traversé les siècles et
aujourd'hui on peut encore visiter le
bâtiment des gardes et la chapelle
restauré au 20e siècle elle a même
trouvé une nouvelle fonction
hospitalière c'est en effet la première
étape du chemin de Saint-Jacques de
Compostelle qui relie Paris à
l'Espagne le 1er mars prochain l'espace
Albert Camu à morpa accueille le
pianiste américain Joakim horsely dans
ba abana il revisite les grands
compositeurs de la musique classique et
la sauce rumba cubaine voici trois
raisons d'aller voir ce spectacle au
micro de Mathilde Francou bonjour je
m'appelle thibo jeanougin je suis
responsable de la programmation
culturelle de la ville de morepas
aujourd'hui j'ai choisi de vous parler
d'un spectacle qui se tiendra le 1er
mars chez nous on reçoit l'incroyable
pianiste Joakim
[Musique]
horsely
les trois raisons d'aller voir ce
spectacle la première c'est pour
découvrir par exemple Beethoven
shostakovic ou encore bac à la sauce
cubaine mais aussi pour découvrir Mozart
Chopin à la sauce afrocaribéenne et
enfin pour passer un moment unique aussi
enjoué
[Musique]
qu'inspiré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce spectacle se tiendra donc à l'espace
Albert Camu le 1er
mars et puis couverte le taitsu est une
discipline inspirée de méthodes de
différents arts martiaux basé sur la
self défense ce sport a été créé en
France dans les années 1970 trois clubs
sont implantés aujourd'hui dans les
ivelines notamment à Montin le breteneux
qui a accueilli un stage national
c'était il y a quelques jours en
présence de l'un des cofondateurs de
cette pratique sportive Nicolas
dandri se protéger se dégager d'une
attaque voilà l'une des multiples
techniques du jitsou littéralement
traduit par technique du corps une
discipline sportive dérivée des ararts
martiaux basé sur la selfdfense donc une
intéressante c'est comme la 1 on a 80
techniques poss possible qui va de la
simple saisie de poignet en passant par
les cheveux les bras et tout bâton
couteau éventuellement chaise matraque
enfin on passe à peu près en vue sachant
que le but principal c'est un sport
Daniel Dubois fait partie des pionniers
du taijitsu une pratique développée en
France dans les années 70 après un
voyage au Japon aujourd'hui le
cofondateur participe à des stages comme
ici au club de Montini le Bretonneux
nous avons quasiment 40 % d'éléments
féminins justement et le but du jeu
malheureusement je dirais c'est d'éviter
savoir comment se défendre en cas
d'agression c'est vraiment un petit peu
ce qui ce qui prévaut au départ pour les
personnes
débutantes le T sou Montin le Bretonneux
c'est 82 adhérents dont une section
enfant ouverte à partir de 6 ans une
discipline pratiqué par tous ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est tout ce
travail d'énergie et pour tout ce qui
est aussi technique comme là des
mouvements de de torsion des cercles qui
nous permettent sans force de pouvoir se
dégager d'une prise éventuellement en
cas extrême on se reçoit pas de vrais
coup on essaie juste de s'en sortir
d'une situation pour limiter du coup le
danger en France plus de 500 personnes
pratiquent le taijitsu ils sont 7000
dans toute
l'Europe
avant l'invité du 78 coup d'œil aux
prévisions météo de
demain demain matin le ciel restera
nuageux dans les ivelines côté
température il fera 11°gr dans la partie
nord du département et 10°gr sur le
reste du territoire de la pluie en
revanche est prévue dans l'après-midi
avec des vents forts par endroit jusqu'à
55 km/h très peu de changement au niveau
du thermomètre compté de 10 à 11°gr dans
les ivelines et ce mercredi 7 février
nous fêterons les Eugénies tout de suite
l'invité du
[Musique]
78 et nous recevons ce soir Émilie le
tailleur bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
conseillère municipal délégué au
handicap dans la commune de jouyan Josas
et vous avez fondé le sing Tang des élus
du handicap du département des élus au
handicap du département des Yvelines
alors depuis octobre ce groupe de
réflexion laboratoire d'idées c'est
comme ça qu'on peut traduire s tank
était informel il est devenu on va dire
un peu plus officiel avec la création
d'une association qui est inscrite
justement au Journal officiel
aujourd'hui elle réunit une dizaine de
membres qui sont élus dans les communes
des ivelines et aussi tous concernés par
cette thématique du handicap quel est le
but de l'association pourquoi l'avoir
créé alors le but de l'association c'est
vraiment de développer de renforcer une
société plus inclusive en lien avec tout
le travail qui a été fait et qui
continue d'être fait par les
associations
qui milite pour le handicap et
rassembler uniquement des élus alors des
élus au handicap et des élus également
qui n'ont pas forcément la délégation
handicap et qui pourrai avoir la mission
du handicap dans leur mission donc je
pense par for par exemple un hlie au
sport qui qui pourrait s'intéresser au
handicap là par exemple par rapport au
Para au Jeux paralympiques ça peut être
un élu à l'éducation donc le but c'est
qu'on puisse vraiment intégrer la
transversalité au niveau ce s tank donc
c'est des élus aussi bien au handicap
mais des élus qui vont être concernés
plus généralement par cette thématique
au travers de de leur délégation vous le
dites alors bah pourquoi cette
association était nécessaire est-ce que
il y a une certaine méconnaissance
encore aujourd'hui sur le le sujet du
handicap alors il y a une méconnaissance
il y a une complexité moi en fait au
début de mon mandat j'ai eu le souhait
vraiment de me rapprocher de mes
homologues en fait élus en handicap pour
m'inspirer hein de de bonnes pratiques
et en fait j'ai pu identifier vraiment
l'isolement de l'élu handicap parce que
doit connaître tout l'écosystème du
handicap qui est très large euh des
éléments juridique techniqu li notamment
l'accessibilité et cetera et puis il il
doit aussi convaincre les autres élus du
bien fondé en fait de ces des sujets qui
souhaitent porter donc ça ça demande
beaucoup à l'élu et aussi j'ai constaté
par rapport au permanence que j'ai mis
en place dans ma ville des familles qui
sont vraiment démunies aussi par rapport
au complexité administrative donc le but
voilà vraiment prenant ces constats je
me suis dit que ce serait beaucoup plus
pertinent et impactant de d'avoir
vraiment cette cette association pour à
la fois faciliter le rôle de l'élu
l'outiller le
professionnaliser continuer à partager
nos pratiques à développer des
expérimentations et surtout faire bouger
les lignes faire bouger la société et ça
veut dire être force de proposition sur
des projets de loi notamment législatif
on va parler peut-être aussi de de ces
bonnes idées que vous pourriez faire
remonter au maire au députés mais
pourquoi pas aussi au gouvernement alors
le département desin a la compétence
sociale et elle comprend justement la
thématique du handicap aujourd'hui il y
a 83000 personnes qui bénéficient d'un
droit auprès de la Maison de l'autonomie
du du département l'idée c'est aussi
d'être complémentaire avec ce qui existe
aujourd'hui oui bien entendu on va pas
tout révolutionner hein le but c'est
travailler main dans la main en
coconstruction justement avec les
différents les différentes instances
bien bien entendu le appartement la MDPH
la région et tout et tous les acteurs
qui qui militent sur le sujet mais on a
le sentiment aujourd'hui qu'il y a
beaucoup d'organes beaucoup
d'interlocuteurs sur sur cette
thématique vous le disiez tout à l'heure
les les familles peuvent se retrouver
parfois démunies c'est aussi d'essayer
de simplifier de mutualiser pour être un
peu plus efficace aussi oui tout à fait
parce qu'en fait on s'aperçoit chaque
élu dans dans sa ville a a vraiment une
connaissance terrain rencontre les
familles et on s'aperçoit que la
l'expérience qui a été réalisée par
exemple PL joui peut aider un élu dans
sa ville à carrière sous poissi par
exemple ou à Villepreux ou à versaill
donc on va mutualiser nos pratiques pour
vraiment structurer nos démarches et
être aussi en en mode j'allais dire être
beaucoup plus impactant dans nos
propositions alors une dizaine de
membres aujourd'hui est-ce que ça
représente toute la carte je si je puis
dire des ivelines est-ce qui est aussi
bien de la petite commune de la grande
commune de la commune moyenne ça va
d'une petite ville de 2000 habitants
jusqu'à plus de 80000 habitants d'accord
donc euh des villes comme Versailles
nous avons donc villepr et carrière
soupassi qui nous ont rejoint récemment
Buc h nous avons aussi Montini le
Bretonneux les chevreuses je dois en
oublier quelques-unes mais en tout cas
voilà on a de plus en plus de villes qui
nous rejoignent et qui ont envie de de
travailler avec nous est-ce qu'il est
difficile pour vous d'identifier dans
ces communes des élus qui sont en charge
du du handicap est-ce que toutes les
communes aujourd'hui ont des délégation
au handicap ou c'est pas encore le cas
alors toutes les communes n'ont pas de
délégation même si de plus en plus quand
même le maire choisit de de choisir un
élu donc comme c'est nouveau c'est pas
forcément encore complètement rentré
dans dans les murs alors bien entendu il
y a des maires adjoints qui sont qui ont
des missions déléguées aux affaires
sociales dont le handicap mais ça va
couvrir en fait un champ très large donc
c'est pas encore quelque chose
d'automatique mais ça ça viendra je
l'espère ça veut dire qu'il y a une
disparité entre les communes sur la la
façon dont est traitée cette thématique
handicap aujourd'hui oui parce que tout
dépend la politique inclusive du maire
le le maire peut peut avoir ce souhait
là après il y a les moyens il y a la y a
la sensibilité et j'allais dire même si
on n pas forcément beaucoup de moyens
une question de bon sens une question de
volonté une question de j'allais dire
d'engagement on peut déjà faire beaucoup
de choses alors on disait donc c'est
échanger ces bonnes pratiques les faire
remonter aussi pourquoi pas au maire
députés et au gouvernement est-ce qu'il
y a déjà eu des des rencontres et qui
avez-vous rencontréou oui tout à fait
alors moi je suis régulièrement en lien
avec Anne bergant ù justement là je lui
ai remonté
récemmentputé oui bien entendu bien
entendu merci pour pour ce rappel là en
fait moi je lui on lui a remonté une
problématique liée en ce moment un
article l'article 53 qui fait un parti
intégrante du PLFSS 2024 plan de loi
financement sécurité sociale et en fait
cet article remet beaucoup en question
les TR les droits fondamentaux des
enfants de la loi 2005 avec des
nouvelles expérimentations ce qui
effraie beaucoup aujourd'hui les
associations parce que les associations
ont l'impression que on repart un peu en
arrière donc moi j'ai j'ai remonter en
expliquant que attention alerte oui on
peut faire évoluer c'estàdire que cet
article 53 veut mettre en place des des
pôles d'appui à la scolarité et que ce
soit l'éducation en fait qui gère toute
la partie c'està-dire que la MDPH n'est
plus le rôle qu'elle a aujourd'hui la
Maison départementale des personnes en
situation de handicap donc il faut
garder quand même une neutralité
aujourd'hui de ces de ces organes qui
qui existe ne pas non plus tout
supprimer voilà donc il peut y avoir des
avancées avec l'éducation parce qu'on a
besoin de l'école inclusive on a besoin
de de de de travailler en transversalité
et en même temps on peut pas non plus
tout tout arrêter et tout supprimer par
rapport à ce qui fonctionne déjà des
sujets prioritaire vous avez parlé de
l'éducation il y a aussi des craintes
liées aux zat qui sont les
établissements et services d'aide par le
le travail ils sont aujourd'hui menacés
ça alors pareil il y a un plan de
transformation un décret qui est passé
la fin décembre 2022 qui veut donc
développer les droits des personnes en
situation de handicap seulement ça
demande une capacité financière des
zades que certains n'ont pas et certains
hates risquent de disparaître
aujourd'hui il y a plus de 30 % d'ates
en difficulté ces ces esates en fait
sont vraiment des lieux d'accueil et
d'inclusion pour les personnes en
situation de handicap aujourd'hui donc
elles ont un travail elles ont elles
sont formées et il y a une utilité elles
ont une utilité sociale donc si
aujourd'hui ces éates disparaissent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait c famille et et
comment accueille-t-il la démarche les
élus que vous avez pu rencontrer alors
ils sont plutôt favorables parce que
effectivement ils ne connaissent pas
forcément le monde des zates et euh ils
sont là aujourd'hui en tout cas il y a
un souhait de remonter ces informations
pour que les lois puissent puissent
évoluer et vous espérez pouvoir
rencontrer pourquoi pas euh des
personnes au gouvernement aussi des
ministres ou oui tout à fait là on
attend justement là ce soir on a le on
attend le le nom on on attend le nom de
de du nouveau ministre ou ou alors fila
catabi qui sera qui sera maintenu donc
là on attend pour pouvoir poursuivre nos
rendez-vous les projets pour l'année
2024 quels sont-ils pour le S tank alors
on continue les projets sur l'éducation
parce que notre souhait ce serait que
les référents handicap de l'éducation
nationale soient beaucoup plus en lien
avec les élus en handicap ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui nous avons des
projets sur l'accessibilité notamment
les places PMR les places mobilité
réduites aujourd'hui les places sont au
normes mais elles ne sont pas
fonctionnelles donc pas prêt pratique il
y a beaucoup de personnes en fauteuil
qui ne peuvent toujours pas se garer et
ça reste quand même très compliqué et
puis l'accessibilité numérique parce que
c'est aussi sont ce sont toujours aussi
des sujets qui sont en retard et qui ne
permettent pas à l'ensemble de la
population ayant des déficiences
visuelles de pouvoir aujourd'hui se
connecter toute dernière question comme
vous êtes une association est-ce que
vous allez aussi demander des
subventions pour pourquoi pas mettre en
place des actions aussi oui tout à fait
c'est notre souhait par la suite là on a
pour le moment une cotisation de l'élu à
l'association et après bien bien entendu
ce serait de pouvoir recueillir des
subventions privées publiques des dons
pour pour assister et soutenir aussi les
les associations et les expérimentations
qu'on souhaite développer merci Émilie
le tailleur d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle présidente du sing Tang des
élus au handicap du département des
ivelines un groupe de réflexion que vous
avez vous-même fondé il y a peu dans le
département merci encore d'avoir été
avec nous voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission euh vous retrouverez demain
pour une nouvelle édition je vais y
arver mailde Francou à la présentation
du 78 très belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78